[Music]
yeah i just went on a really long walk
and i went and walked around all these
fancy neighborhoods in brooklyn and i
started you know i do what what people
do i pull up zillow as i'm walking and
i'm like you know i wonder what it's
like to live here
and the houses that i like what i
usually will do is i see a house and i
go oh i would like to live there and i
pull it up and it's eight million
dollars
and eight million dollars that's one
number but then you actually look at how
much money you need to come up on at
closing and then you look at how much
money you need to uh spend each and
every month on the mortgage and on your
interest and on maintenance and things
like that
and i started thinking
i think i'm gonna live over here in
brooklyn and i wanted to like map out
how much money i would expect uh i would
spend to live the lifestyle i want to
spend and it is astronomical and i
wanted to talk about some some of those
expenses
you want to talk about something walk me
through it okay so listen to this first
of all i'm gonna talk about the life
that i'm gonna live when i move to
brooklyn and all the listeners there's
gonna be a bunch of them that's gonna
say oh sam no one needs an eight million
dollar house yeah i get it you know like
all i need is like a bucket of water and
like some apples and like a pair of
crocs and i'm happy but this is the life
that i choose to live so like i get it
no one needs this but i'm picking this
so get off my back on this hypothetical
case that might be a reality in two
years so i just got to get that out of
the way but in terms of hypotheticals
it's not entirely hypothetical because i
went and talked to a couple friends who
do this but listen to this
so
i found a home that i wanted to buy and
i actually linked to it on the the mbd
master dock okay so it's a street is on
street easy it's a nice house okay it's
only 3 000 square feet though but it's a
brown stone in my favorite neighborhood
of cobble hill it's five million dollars
i actually think the range of things i
want are between five and eight but this
one i just found it was available it's
five million dollars which basically
means i got to come up with 1.1 million
dollars as my down payment and then i'm
going to spend around 20 000 a month
in mortgage and interest and and things
like that not including maintenance
which is going to be uh more expensive
it's going to be probably another two or
three thousand dollars a month
then
i think it would probably cost on the
low end 50 000 on the middle only end of
like 150 000 to furnish it the way i'd
like to furnish it right have you ever
furnished a house
yeah yeah it depends if you go like red
like my wife she's like oh yeah i'm like
what do you like she's like restoration
hardware i'm like ah geez like you know
every item in the like you know 40 000
to 10 000
and so you know you just add that up per
room you're putting in like 20 to 25
grand worth of stuff per per room uh in
the house which is pretty nuts yeah
totally so like 150k is that's just kind
of what it would cost if you want to go
that route if you want to go west m west
elm then yeah you can maybe get it done
for 175 000 but it's quite expensive
then
if i'm going to get this fat house i'm
getting it because i have two kids or a
couple kids so i need my 40
fifty thousand dollar a year nanny i
imagine i would spend around thirty
thousand dollars a year in food and so
basically it comes up to where i think
i'm spending
six hundred to seven hundred thousand
dollars a year to live the life i want
to live in brooklyn but
here's the kicker if you're making over
a million dollars a year in brooklyn or
or for sure in manhattan it's even more
than this
half your money goes away to taxes
so basically if i'm spending around six
hundred thousand dollars a year i need
to make 1.2 million dollars
just to cover my my monthly number break
even just a break even
and if i if it's and i i talked to two
friends one friend who lives in brooklyn
he told me that he spends around 500 000
a year and then another friend that also
lives nearby and he told me he spends
eight hundred thousand dollars a year
and he spent me he sent me his uh list
but he goes i have an uh an additional
house in north uh rhode island but if
you take that uh vacation home we are
spending around 650 000 a year
so to to live like this it's crazy and
when you go and walk on these streets
you know there's a house every block if
you go in manhattan there's this fancy
apartment every block how on earth do
you think people so many people afford
this
it's crazy like when you actually think
about the logistics right well
well a lot of the people who owned these
homes they owned them
before they were worth 5 million so go
look at the you know the zillow history
of this thing
10 years ago what was this home worth
you know i'm guessing it's less than
you know less than half this maybe 35 of
this price 10 years ago 30
and so you're what you're talking about
here is like you know a home that what
that they bought in their basis is a
million million and a half dollars
something like that instead of five so
now the monthly payment is less and now
the property taxes are less and so you
know you cut out your biggest expense in
this case um you you trim that down so i
think that's that's the answer for how a
lot of people have this is inheritance
or um or buying in you know 20 years ago
15 years ago
when these were worth a fraction of what
they're worth today and so that's why
they can afford to kind of live above
their weight well so i had four
takeaways when i started thinking about
this the first was that there's a story
behind everything so all these people
like a simpleton like me is like oh you
just got to earn this much money and
they did it by starting a business it's
like no that's not the reality and zach
crockett who works at the hustle he
basically we were talking about this and
he was going to write a story on this
and he said that he researched a bunch
of these homes and what he did was he uh
for all the five million dollar bro for
a bunch of five million dollar brown so
it's an nyc he used a tool called
melissa and he looked up the property
records then he googled the names uh of
each person who quote owned it and then
he like looked at their family records
which she just did this all through just
sleuthing and like looking through stuff
and he found out that a bunch of them
like seven out of ten of them were like
teachers or artists or
or or a professor things that you
basically like you can earn a bunch of
money but you're not earning enough
money to buy this home and what he
surmised and came to the conclusion was
like they just get a lot of help and so
like it's hard to own a five million
dollar brownstone when you're a reporter
at the new york post or something like
you know
120 000 your job so i think there's a
story behind everything the second thing
is i think you just have to earn a lot
of money dude listen to this if you earn
uh one hang on
hang on
that was a
killer insight what
the you got to earn a lot of money
yeah where did you come up with that
you got to earn a lot of money but
listen let's let's put the math on this
how many how many years do you think you
need to uh how long will it take you to
save 10 million dollars if you lived in
new york to save 10 million
yeah to get a portfolio of 10 million
i have no idea i don't know let's say 20
years
okay so if you make 1.5 million dollars
and you're spending around 25 000 a
month in living expenses it's gonna take
you around 15 years to be able to save
10 million dollars which is pretty crazy
now you've got to figure out how to earn
at least a million and a half for 10
years
or for 13 years which is like
that in itself is impossible or not
impossible very very very challenging
and so
hold on you refer your first thing was
like these people are teachers and
artists you said they got to have some
help you're talking about like family
help you're not talking about like
there's nothing else right you're saying
you have rich family
yeah
okay all right sorry i carry on i think
that i think just having a like i
underestimated that when i think about
this i'm like whose parents would give
them two million dollars for a down
payment on a home and i think the answer
to that is actually a lot
i can i i can't imagine that but the
answer like that that was hard for me to
because you know i don't know
that my mom and dad like the best gift
they ever gave me was when i turned 21
they gave me a thousand dollars and that
was like the last birthday present i
ever got i i don't even think it's a
down payment it's okay you're a teacher
great your down payment is covered where
are you coming up with 25k a month of
your monthly monthly payment just for
your home like they get allowed
this is a this is an all cash
here's your house free and clear you get
to live here and you cover your life
expenses if you're paying for a latte
that's you but uh i'll buy you this
brownstone i think that's got to be what
it is
i think that's that that has to be what
it is or the second thing is you gotta
earn a lot the third thing is i think
you gotta i want how many of them do you
think sell a business i think earning a
lot like a big nut of 10 20 million
dollars
it seems like impossible to do without
selling an asset
you got to be in finance law
um maybe medicine or consulting to be
pulling in a million dollars a year of
income i i don't think there are many
other jobs
that do that we're not talking about
athletes entertainers because it's just
a small such a small portion of the
population but of jobs that a normal
person can get that's going to make you
a million to two million dollars a year
i'm pretty sure you've got to be either
a banker or a banker or consultant if
you're employed or you got to be
self-employed as a doctor or a lawyer or
something like that to be able to pull
that in so that's like am i missing one
that's like those are john
yeah those are non-entrepreneurial jobs
like the other ways and then you can
start your small business
yeah yeah exactly you own a small
business you own a big business you um
you know you own a contracting firm you
do construction around the city whatever
it is those are the other way where you
can do this and that's usually
you're not earning some steady 1.5
million per year you're earning like
nothing nothing nothing a lot a lot lot
huge and then back to nothing you know
like that sort of thing it's this it's
this lumpy curve that an entrepreneur
has where you're basically broke till
you're very unbroke um
so yeah
but
uh yeah what else you got to say about
this and my third and final takeaway
here is basically
there's so much out there there's so
much money out there there is so much
opportunity you walk by all these places
and again ben's laughing at me this is
obvious but it when you see it in real
life i walk down the street and i'm like
oh that apartment that cost 12 000 a
month to rent in that top floor of that
brown store stone and there's three of
those in there so like there's three
people each paying 12 000 and they're
just like home home home home home home
home it's astronomical there's just so
much money out there to be made it's
just so much opportunity so anyway i did
this three hour walk yesterday and i
just
i felt enlightened and i just wanted to
come to the table and fill you in on
that
[Music]
you